eric pinon économiste et professeur à
l'institut des sciences de
l'environnement de l'uqam est notre
invité ce soir bonsoir
éric pineault bonsoir vous étudié de
près ces questions de ressources de
développement des ressources est ce que
est ce qu'elle est ce que la raison
fondamentale c'est quoi selon vous pour
cette décision de tes cris sur la raison
fondamentale est essentiellement
économique
et à voir avec le prix du baril
essentiellement qu'antec formule le
projet frontières on est dans une
période où le prix du baril est
extrêmement élevé on est dans autour des
90 100 dollars le baril donc avant 2000
qu on est en 2014 d'eau et 2013 2014
jusqu'en 2015 on dépose de projets en
2015 et là c'est le processus
réglementaire qui suit son cours on
arrive aujourd'hui en 2020 le baril
était à 51 dollar ce matin
si on prend le prix en amérique du nord
et dans ces documents tels didier on a
besoin d'un prix entre 80 et 90 dollars
pour commencer à creuser et on vise une
fois qu'on commence à produire en 2025
un prix du baril autour de 95 dollars
on est loin des doigts on est à 51 et si
on regarde les trois quatre prochaines
années tout le monde parle d'un
ralentissement économique mondial à
venir ce qui veut dire un prix du
pétrole qui vont rester bas et surtout
en amérique du nord qui nage dans les
surplus de pétrole depuis qu'on a aussi
ma fracture et finalement tu vois cette
nouvelle économie pétrolière en amérique
du nord
donc le prix des pôles a clairement
est-ce que la mésentente entre l'alberta
et le gouvernement fédéral et plusieurs
autres provinces qui vont jusqu'à
contester en cour le prix sur le carbone
imposée par le gouvernement fédéral est
ce que le grand patron de take her
raison c'est une vraie raison pour dire
on va pas de l'avant que le projet ça
crie beaucoup d'incertitudes sacré
l'incertitude on for finance & tech le
projet frontières doit et de finance il
ya beaucoup d'incertitudes
en termes de politique climatique
canadienne mais en termes aussi les
politiques climatiques aussi dans 20 ans
on va et où alors qu'un projet qu'il
gênait beaucoup d'incertitudes
les actions financières de plus en plus
sont frileuses d'engager des sommes
considérables dans des projets à haute
intensité de carbone de haute intensité
de co2 donc le financement était
peut-être fragiles et donc oui
l'incertitude des politiques climatiques
canadienne
et le système à deux vitesses finalement
un alberto qui veut aller de l'avant
très agressivement et en fédérale qui
tente de ménager la chèvre et le chou ça
n'aide pas je pense que une conjoncture
politique beaucoup plus global qui est
les politiques climatiques qui font que
ce type de projet l'on ne reçoit pas du
moins dans des économies comme
l'économie canadienne depuis favorable
ouais mais si le prix du pétrole est à
80 90 ans dans la hotte un débat tech ne
se serait pas n'aurait pas retirer son
projet de gouvernement serait très
embêté je pense qu'on sera l'hiver un
espace d'entente ont dit on va mettre un
cap sur les émissions du secteur des
sables bitumineux et on va permettre
texte arrêté un espèce de compromis un
peu un peu à la reggina plie donc
l'ancienne première ministre de
l'alberta qui avec l'industrie s'est
entendu on veut mettre un chapeau on
veut dire voici sera en dessous de quoi
le secteur doit rester et en même temps
on perd mais le sort de certains projets
il faut s'appliquer deux ans le pdg de
suncor ils disaient c'est fini les
grands projets là maintenant quand on
inaugure le dernier grand complexe que
celui de fort qu'ils ont dit dorénavant
on est en consolidation contrôle des
coûts améliorations de productivité et
plus du tout dans l'expansion plan
l'ouverture de deux pourquoi roger parce
que les prix ne sont pas les entrées
sont pollock simplement et parle en
dormant dehors et la demande seulement
de cirque est très lourd on vienne on
vient dire que le pétrole l'eau ne sera
pas utilisé le bon coeur fuel qu'on dit
paul et le programme aviation
commerciale c'est fini le nian horizon
laquelle on veut l'éliminer il savait du
gnl ou du gaz naturel ou d'autres types
de carburant qu'on va utiliser donc les
perspectives de marché sont pas très
bonnes pour ce type de pétrole là on en
a besoin mais peut-être pas aussi grande
quantité est donc dans ce contexte le
mieux vaut utiliser la capacité
extractives et augmenter sa rentabilité
pourquoi tu ici énergie transcanada et
aller de l'avant avec cost oil gas link
sachant très bien que les chef
héréditaire qui avaient des chefs
héréditaire qui s'opposaient à ce projet
qui traversait le territoire où est
souhaité m alors qu'aujourd'hui texte
dit je n'irai pas de l'avant pour toutes
sortes de raisons là qui ont été
énumérées par l'entreprise avec le
projet frontière parce qu'on est dans
une autre réalité économique
dans le cas de take on est dans des
sables bitumineux on est dans un baril
de pétrole avec un prix des premiers ici
on est dans une nouvelle économie qui
émerge l'économie du gaz naturel issu de
fracturation donc non conventionnels les
sources de gaz conventionnel le canada
est un important exportateur de gaz
naturel quatrième au monde
mais ce qu'on exporte actuellement si du
gaz conventionnel celle du réservoir
dans lequel on mar ont tué le garde ça
sous pression parce dans un réseau
d'oléoducs et de gazoducs qui s'en vont
partout en amérique du nord
ce modèle est en train de tirer à sa fin
nous réserves conventionnelles sont
presque vides
par contre on a des réserves qu'on dit
non conventionnel qu'il faut atteindre
par fracturation hydraulique et là le
nom à retenir c'est maintenant c'est une
immense formations géologiques entre
l'alberta et la colombie exactement et
sur la fronti leçon la frontière
l'essentiel du gaz et du côté lacombe le
britannique
du côté de l'alberta on a plutôt du
pétrole ok on compte qu'on extrait par
fracturation
comment on fait un appel à shia comment
on fait hodac auteurs comme on fait dans
le permis au texas et là on est dans les
mêmes prix qu'ailleurs en amérique du
nord en termes de coûts d'extraction
donc la rentabilité économique elle est
présente
par contre on peut pas envoyer savoir le
sud parce que le réseau de gazoducs et
saturé trop de gaza ne brille dinars et
donc même si on dit on va remplacer le
charbon même si on il faut le sortir du
continent et ça nous donne donc une
trajectoire vers l'océan pacifique pour
exporter sous forme liquide et il ya une
économie pour gérer une économie en
marche c'est plus que pour les prix des
sables bitumineux les prix du pétrole
sont passés oui parce qu'on est là on
est dans un produit qui dont la demande
est encore en progression
il ya une course actuellement lieu la
demande de gnl on sait que dès lors de
gaz naturel liquéfié
donc on sait qu'elle est là et une
course en ce moment pour construire la
capacité de liquéfaction entre
l'amérique en amérique du nord entre le
golfe du mexique entre le bcm est ici à
alès ton avec gnl québec donc une course
a construit la capacité et et après son
allégeance position
dans cette nouvelle économie du gaz qui
vraiment changé la donne
merci beaucoup pour ses explications ce
soir